hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so let's talk about
eukaryotes and how glycerol
phospholipids are made in them since
we've already talked about prokaryotes
so we know that eukaryotes can do both
methods one and two to make their
glycerophospholipids but since we talked
about method one with the prokaryotes
I'll just continue by talking about
method one here so we'll take phosphated
a add to it some CTP and then the CMP
portion from that gets added onto
phosphate a date while at pyrophosphate
comes off we get our activated I sub
literal in CDP d AG now this is
activated ready to go for the addition
of polar head group alcohols to be
attached to this red phosphate group
here and knock the CMV off so let's say
we added phosphatidyl glycerol to the
CDP d AG what would happen well what's
kind of number this here first number
this is carbons 1 2 & 3 over here and
we'll call call this 1 2 & 3 but we'll
make all those Prime's so that'll be 1
prime 2 Prime and three prime and so
here what ends up happening is that the
3 prime Oh H ends up being the one
that's connected to the phosphate group
while the CMP group falls off so we've
got this is going to be 3 prime carbon
here 2 prime 1 prime then the phosphate
group and then this is going to be
carbon number 3 2 & 1
ok and that gives us cardio lie pin
which is a molecule that we saw in the
previous video and this process is
catalyzed by cardiolipin
synthase specifically the eukaryotic
version of that enzyme so how is this
how is forming cardio life in here
different than how it occurs bacteria
well one thing is that here we have a
eukaryotic enzyme so that's different
whereas over before
we have the bacterial enzyme another
thing is that hearing eukaryotes we
started off with CDP d AG and we added
plus to the glycerol to get cardio type
in whereas in the prokaryotes that's not
what happened we had two phosphatidyl
glycerols that condense together to give
cardio life in so that's I really wanted
to mention that here as just a
difference between the two now another
way to make another of listro
phospholipid is adding this alcohol and
NOS at all and if we add an acetal to
replace the cmp here and cmp will fall
off and the inositol will get added the
this this o h here this number one o h
on an acetal will actually be connected
to this phosphate group the red one as a
CMP falls off and we'll get phosphatidyl
inositol shown here and so that's that
linkage that was made there and now so
that was basically our step 3 right our
step 3 in that that was the addition of
the polar head group alcohol and that
was catalyzed by phosphatidyl inositol
synthase that makes sense it's just
making phosphatidyl inositol and now
that phosphatidyl inositol can be
modified in our step 4 now step 4 by
specific
Hospital inositol kinase is which will
add phosphates to carbons or to the OHS
on carbon four and five of inositol so
these two carbon these two O H is this
one here and this one here will get
phosphate groups attached to them and
that will these are kinase is that where
these phosphates are coming from so you
imagine they're coming from ATP and will
add two so that each of those groups
gets a phosphate group and that gives us
phosphatidyl inositol four five this
phosphate sometimes known as pip two and
that is important because it's we've
seen it before in the ip3 daj signaling
pathway now we've got specific organisms
that we're going to use as examples here
so yeast yeast does eukaryote and we're
going to see a specific example of how
how we might make a glycerophospholipid
in yeast so we can start with CDP D AG
just like before and we can add our
alcohol serine specifically the alcohol
group serine and we'll kick off the CMP
here just as a reminder this whole
portion is the CMP and that will replace
the CMP we'll get that serine portion
attached there to give us phosphatidyl
serine and phosphatidylserine can give
us phosphatidyl ethanolamine if we just
have a decarboxylation step to get rid
of that and with this so we've actually
seen that before in prokaryotes this is
happening just like it happened in
prokaryotes rise to those first few
steps are pretty much just like well
it's similar to prokaryotes or bacteria
right so we made faucet o ethanol amine
just like we did with prokaryotes now
what can happen is we can have a further
modification right so this
decarboxylation step was a step
for right a modification we could
further modify this
phosphatidylethanolamine and turn it
into phosphatidylcholine by basically
replacing these hydrogens here on this
amino group these three hydrogens we
replace them with three methyl groups
and what that's going to require is
that's going to require 3 1 carbon
transfers 3 1 carbon transfers and we're
going to add 3 methyl groups from a
specific donor that donor molecule is
Sam okay so we're gonna have three
molecules of Sam donate a methyl group
each and each one each of those methyl
groups will be attached to that nitrogen
from that amino group and these Sam's
will become si H's so Sam is s
adenosylmethionine and si H is
s-adenosyl homocysteine
how do those molecules look they look
like this let's see here sort of reveal
what's going on here
okay so that's Sam right there and just
below it will put will show you sa H so
that's s a dino SIL al homocysteine so
why do these names make sense and which
is the methyl group it's actually
donated well it's called s
adenosylmethionine the dental seal comes
from the adenine portion that's that's
up here right this is adenine up here
right that's the adenine so that's where
the identity all comes from especially
cuz it's the ribose here
adenine ribose and then over here we've
got the addendum sealed portion is
attached to this sulfur right which is
part of this whole thing over here with
it which would be meth ine right that
portion there defining
and so this methyl group is actually the
group that's donated from Sam to the
phosphatidyl ethanolamine that we just
saw a moment ago and when it's gone that
become that the molecule changes its
structure to look like this right this
methyl group is now gone there's no
longer a plus charge there and we have
si don't still homeless cysteine so this
molecule over here would be the amino
acid homocysteine so that process you
know where Sam is acting as a one carbon
donor is catalyzed by a methyl
transferase enzyme to give us boss
acetyl choline so this is yet another
step for ish kind of molecule or C step
for is kind of step or reaction right
and now we are modifying an existing
glycerophospholipid just to a different
letter o phospholipid okay so now that's
how it works in yeast let's see how it
works in mammals slide this on over all
right we got mammals now okay so let's
say that we're starting from a CDP d AG
again an activated d AG you want to add
serine just like we did before in yeast
to give us phosphatidyl serine okay
let's say we wanted to do that well in
mammals that's going to be a no no that
does not happen this this particular
glycerophospholipid phosphatidylserine
in mammals
although mammals can have both method
one and Method two both occur method
method one is not used to make
phosphatidylserine it's not made from
CDP d AG the activated d AG right it's
not made from method one instead it's
made from the activated alcohol which is
method - okay now I'm not actually going
to draw that I encourage you to try it
on your own after I show you two
different examples so I'm going to show
you how to make phosphatidyl
ethanolamine and phosphatidylcholine
and hopefully you can apply what we
learned here to try to do
phosphatidylserine on your own
okay so we've got ethanolamine here just
the alcohol and the first thing that
we're going to do is we're going to
activate it by adding an ATP and then
with a DP comes off and this is done by
ethanolamine kinase so question over
here is listed does it make sense to be
investing energy here the answer is yes
right we're talking about biosynthesis
right so biosynthesis is anabolic
requires energy or can require energy so
anabolism occurs often we have a high
energy state anyway okay anyway a little
bit sidetracked
we've got ethanolamine kinase right a
kinase that adds a phosphate to ethanol
I mean to give us this new molecule so
which is just ethanol amine with a
phosphate group on the end so that's
going to be phosphoethanolamine name
makes sense now when we have
phosphoethanolamine we're going to turn
that into CDP ethanol amine so in order
to do that we have to invest a CTP which
has three phosphates and we're really
only attaching this purple portion which
only has one phosphate so we're adding a
CMP essentially the other two phosphates
must be gone as a pyrophosphate the
enzyme that accomplishes this is CTP
ethanolamine site it'll transferase
let's kind of break down that name a
little bit so that's kind of complicated
CTP ethanolamine and CTP working with
phosphoethanolamine site it'll transfer
race we're transferring this side of the
in portion over to this ethanol amine
okay or phosphoethanolamine to get CDP
ethanol amine okay so now we have CDP
ethanol amine what we're going to do is
this is basically the activated alcohol
right so once we have actually make the
note of that here this is the activated
alcohol right ready to go so now we just
need to die so glycerol to come in
so we'll all comes in and it's going to
basically kick off the CDP or should be
the cmp portion the purple portion here
that's going to fall off and the dice
what's wrong basically going to take its
place
specifically the O H or the oxygen in on
the third carbonate da G is going to
connect to the phosphate group to give
us that head group and that will give us
phosphatidyl ethanolamine that process
is catalyzed by CDP ethanolamine
diacylglycerol phosphoethanolamine
transferase again a mouthful but that
should make a little bit of sense we're
talking about an interaction between CDP
ethanolamine and DA G so that's where
that part comes from phosphoethanolamine
transferase we're just transferring this
phosphoethanolamine portion over we're
basically just taking this part of the
molecule and we're putting it here we're
just putting it right there right and
then the CMP portion leaves and so that
gives us plus two ethanolamine okay now
these same process can happen to give
you fossil choline so I'll run through
that kind of quickly just to make sure
that this video isn't too long but I
still would encourage you to try to slow
it down and maybe you'd think about what
these enzyme names might be yourself but
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to invest in ATP to give
phosphocholine sorry we're starting with
choline and the enzyme is going to be a
kinase as well
Colleen kinase is acting on choline once
we have that phospho choline we're going
to add a CTP and a pyrophosphate will
come off and we'll have the enzyme B CTP
choline site it'll transferase again
just transferring that site any portion
over now we have a CDP choline and that
cmp portion is going to fall off and be
replaced by the d AG right so that we
can get that phospho choline portion
basically attached to the third carbons
oxygen on the dice a twister Oh that'll
be catalyzed by CDP choline
diacylglycerol
phosphocholine transferase again
transferring this portion right here to
give us phosphatidylcholine that's the
process there now we could have also
done is instead of that whole right side
happening once we got phosphatidyl
ethanolamine we could have just turned
that into plus 2ax choline with three
one carbon transfers of Sam to give
these three methyl groups to
phosphatidylethanolamine to make
phosphatidylcholine so that could have
happened there and again that's another
modification to give a
glycerophospholipid so i hope that video
and that video series was helpful
thank you for watching thanks for
watching don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and be sure to share the video
with anyone who you think might find
helpful thanks and happy studying